let's verify that the margin mechanics
and the marking to market of the futures
contract actually gets both the seller
and the buyer what they originally
wanted which is that they don't have to
be susceptible to the volatility in
Apple prices they both wanted to
effectively sell the apples for 20 cents
a pound or buy the apples for 20 cents a
pound and they didn't want to in the
farmers case go out of business if they
could only sell the apples for 10 cents
a pound or in the pie company's case go
out of business if they had to buy the
apples for 30 cents a pound
so let's verify that this works out so
they originally had a contract price of
$200 4,000 pounds so this is essentially
20 cents a pound 20 cents a pound and as
we said in the previous video as the
futures contract delivery price changes
day by day as we get closer and closer
to the actual delivery date what happens
is is that we transfer money between the
buyers margin account and the sellers
margin account as the price of as the
delivery price on the future contract
goes down in order to mark the delivery
price down so in order to mark it down
from $200 to $190 to $185 this guy keeps
getting a better deal on the actual
delivery price so to make things fair he
has to transfer the same amount of money
to the margin account of the seller so
let's imagine two scenarios let's say
that eventually as we approach November
15th remember this is the delivery date
the delivery the futures contract
delivery price is going to approach the
market price you can imagine right when
we're like a second before the delivery
date the futures contract and the market
price aren't going to be that different
and let's say that this goes let's say
that this goes all the way down to $100
so in that whole process this futures
contract keeps getting marked down to
$100 so on that day it is true that the
seller will sell a thousand pounds of
apples to the buyer for only $100 so you
might say hey wait what did the seller
get out of this he's only getting 10
cents per pound for his apples this was
what he feared he's susceptible to the
volatility of the market prices but
remember because of this marking the
market and because of the the margin
transfers here
this delivery price went down from $200
to $100 there would have been a transfer
from this guy's margin account to this
guys margin account of of $100 so
instead of just getting the hundred
dollars for that thousand pounds of
apples because this seller had this
futures contract he would have also got
another hundred dollars transferred into
his margin account so his economic the
true economic value he gets is two
hundred dollars no matter what for his
thousand pounds of apples or 20 cents a
pound you can imagine the other scenario
what if the delivery price is we get
closer and closer to delivery date goes
up if it goes to three hundred dollars
three hundred dollars per thousand
pounds well you might say hey the seller
is going to get a bonanza and this guy's
going to go out of business because he's
going to be essentially paying 30 cents
per pound but you got to remember if the
price went up and this becomes and it
becomes more and more favorable to the
seller because of the margin mechanics
the seller would have to transfer a
hundred dollars over the as the price
moves up to the buyer to his margin
account and so even though this guy has
to pay $300 per pound because that's
where the market price eventually ended
up he would get a hundred dollars from
the seller so effectively he would still
only have to pay $200 and even though
this guy's selling it for $300 he
actually had to pay another hundred
dollars so net he's really only getting
$200 for it so no matter how you look at
it both parties are transacting at $200
or 20 cents a pound